今天量人急動不到1000不到1兆
不到9000億不到8000億
怎麼會這樣量人急動
台股不行了嗎?
下週要變盤嗎?
是今天關盤重點
今天我們節目重點之一
第二個美債飆破40兆
前幾年還不到30兆
現在飆破40兆美金
台股是不是經燥
債務會不會引爆股災?
這個很重要
第三個
主動型ETF很多開始賣國具的
貝豆元件完了嗎
連日本的春田製作所股價
看起來要打第二隻腳
國具還要再破500元嗎
那其他貝豆元件不就死定了嗎
今天所有的標股介紹還有大盤的行情
我一次講個夠
今天台股開低走高
最後漲了290點
收漲在45224點
投資朋友們都有發現到台股量能明顯萎縮
加上昨晚美股很震盪
大家都很好奇主要原因到底是什麼呢?
話說回來投資上的股票還是表現不錯
投資上的群聯今天逆勢走強
又重新占回2000元大關啦
投資上的國距今天在平盤附近震盪
隨時準備要發動啦
有些投資朋友很擔心0098EA賣股
但你想知道投資長是怎麼看的嗎
你還沒上車
手上還沒有標股嗎
接下來就交給我們經濟日報
選股冠軍單計188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析器
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily各位大家好
哇今天台灣股市
亮梭
是
怎麼辦
量縮就很難股票很難噴出去
真的
所以今天看到根本人今天長金融股
長一些CPU 長到航運股
腰膜鬼怪都出來了
航運股不算腰膜鬼怪
可是他跟AI沒有什麼扯上什麼關係
所以怎麼會這樣子
量縮你自己看大盤量縮
Ganne
是不是
7100億 是不是7192億
你看是不是近期新低
反彈沒量產的啦
我今天量怎麼可以這麼縮
8000 3000 7000 1000
這個7000不成比例了
這個有問題啊
量一直在縮
怎麼那麼慘
怎麼辦
這個有點問題
沒關係大概這邊
量一直在縮啦
這麼低的量縮
今天還有8000多
昨天要8000多
還有1兆的
現在變7000億的
前陣子這邊的時候還有1.5兆
這碗左一點有1.5兆以上
是不是
怎麼會差這麼多
現在變0.7兆了
是
苔果是不是金兆
是不是
怎麼會這樣子呢
量說真的很難出標股
只會出那一種
有人說汙染出標股
能夠出那種單一阻力的標股
拱不上去賞我很麻煩
我又不是說我看到串見大漲
我就跟你講 我今天有串鍵 我今天 哇 望海
牙名漲 望海漲 我就跟你講 我有航運股
不是這樣啦 不是說股票有漲 我做事都是我的
我不做這種事 老頭顧的事情我不做 這樣也會出事我不喜歡
我會做你是不是為了出事我不喜歡講這種好話
所以我告訴大家怎麼辦 我在這邊要怎麼辦的時候 我們先來一首歌 好不好
好不好 這是符合我們的歌詞
好不好 讚讚我歌
有沒有聽過那個
說說說說你愛我
是不是大舌頭是不是 是
那台股也是說 說到不行嗎
真的喔 從說到不行 到怎麼樣
到滿手套牢 到冷過低潮
轉野股價串清高
讓你衝衝衝 轉轉轉
從這邊 我們開始
小哈 瑞迪好了嗎 好
我們瑞迪 插吧
說說說說說到不行
慢慢慢慢慢慢受逃老
人人人人人過低潮
一轉眼骨架創新高
衝衝衝衝衝 衝破千高
包包包包包 包進包老
轉轉轉轉轉 轉到發飆
這一波在乎翻白白
喔不錯
想要你應該站在另外一邊
真的不錯我們知道
說說說到不行
慢慢滿手套牢
很多人現在被人念套牢
人人人人過低潮啊
一專業股價穿新高
你要冷過啊
才會衝衝衝衝衝破錢高
爆爆爆緊爆了
賺到發票這一波財富翻百倍
你翻百倍那很誇張啦
那麽翻倍就開心了好不好
股市沒有一定
但如果就是我預期的一個10萬點
我講不清你啊
我講的是
5年內甚至4年內
甚至可能更快
我跟大家講可能更快
我明天跟他開玩笑
你要去了解AI
昨天有說Modena,這MRNA的疫苗
同樣你要去瞭解這些邏輯
那時候接下來台灣股市怎麼走
我們先慢慢講那些總經鏈好不好
好
因為總經鏈很多可以講
等一下
看一下台灣股市的走勢度
先看台美股市
有沒有
廢半了,最近納斯拉克打第二隻腳
可是就好像講的
納斯拉克今年大概展12%左右
所以他沒有理由再一次破敵
AEI還是無眼伯借第二個
費辦今年好像展了好像快60%
如果沒有記錯的話快60%
快60%以上 曾經60%以上
拉回或怎麼辦
你不用擔心 台灣股市拉克是費辦加納斯拉克的指數平均漲幅
OK嗎 加起來處於2
這兩個最近看起來沒破底
可是他們也沒很強
台灣股市看起來還要一下晚上潑
一副晚上閃的樣子
台灣股市已經偷笑
可是台灣股市現在散戶該進來的都進來
該套牢都套牢了
大家可以看被動員警知道
所以最大問題是美國股市也要死不活
美國股市要受到美國公債的影響
昨天不是說美國公債有機會
可是有機會也不會這麼快就解決
因為必信債務越滾越大
像滾雪球般嘛
美工在直率又再度彈升
昨天把他壓下來嘛
我說很簡單
2007年跟現在
這是美在直率有沒有
這是30之前期美在直率
這個是美在直率
這是費的利率有沒有
有
這費的利率好
所以美在直率
2007年戳破泡沫
不是美在直率戳破泡沫
2007年是費的利率戳破泡沫
你看現在美在直率是5.31
然後呢 五點三一 可費得率3.63
有沒有 他們差很大 以前差不了多少
是
那其實美在直率怎麼低
基本上不會低於費得率率
這很簡單 為什麼
我不要 我每在直率我低於費得率率
我去存定存就好 我買什麼美在
對不對 沒錯吧
所以美在直率喔 5.31
可是現在費得率3.63
好不好 定存利率就是以這個為主的
至少有操作空間
所以曾經打壓他去買美債
買30年期美債
賣出比較短的10年期的美債
這個先不要叫大家太多
買美債 美債價格就往上了
直率就往下滑
打下去了 打下去以後就今天又拉起來了
大家覺得真的假的 不要擔心
美國財政部長他是非常優秀的
他是那個
你索羅斯的徒弟
不是索羅斯 他真的也叫索羅斯
翻譯翻譯
華爾街那麼老 華爾街
華爾街那個民私出高徒
所以索羅斯的徒弟他是真的華爾街
所以他在很靈活的
我覺得還是有機會
你看像美國現在以前應該講
一年兩千萬噸的石油
應該現在早就有問題
反而美國反而沒問題
美國反而賺寶寶
好不好 很奇怪
核武之害俠不是被封鎖嗎
油價怎麼沒有到140
連100都沒有
所以這都是他們的節奏 很厲害
操縱金融含情
只是他們要不要做而已
只是跟大家講
就是現在要死不活
可是我昨天要跟大家講
我說古災記起來
很多人說古災
古災通常爆發
爆發的時候對不對
通常最晚的時候頂多到9月是差不多了
現在8、9月了差不多了
之前有人那時候留言說
哲哲你講錯了
你講出2022年的時候
2022年 歡迎來挑戰我
我不能說這個 我只是印象而已
2022年的時候股災在10月份
沒有 你們看一下
2022年對不對
2022年是一整年都股災好不好
我說沒錯吧
這10月份
10月份這邊有沒有
10月25號 12629
你知道
這10月份
10月份這邊有沒有對不對
對
它從是吧
它從3月 2月開始
從1月5號開始 怎麼辦
一整年 一直跌
就是升息含情
所以我最怕台灣股市一直升息
因為資金會被抽走
那美在直流一直漲 也不行
股市就怕沒有資金 懂不懂
所以那一整年
你不能說 哇 第一點見到10月
就是10月的股災沒有
我講的是通常爆發性的股災
你看關稅 319槍擊案很多的事情
關稅是不是 2016年那時候好像也有2016年17年
中美貿易戰 那時候是9月10月
可是我告訴你 如果景氣循環所造成的那種
比如5窮6學73調
其實大部分頂多到8、9月就結束了
大部分要走空 精氣的衰退
9月之前就會結束 不會說9月才突然發生
但第一點有的時候是10月 有時候是11月
金融海嘯是11月 那不一樣
因為它可能5月發生 比較10月是有這樣子
5月發生 然後到11月 這是有的
可是不通常不會 9月 10月它給你爆發一個金融海嘯
要能不能到景氣的海峽
懂嗎?OK嗎?
那最近難什麼?
來
為什麼陽明長?
我告訴大家為什麼陽明長
我也認為現在不要追陽明
不要追萬海
既然中石屋大陸就是做一波道
你去問所有的業界人都知道
這很厲害
好懂moderna
好懂疫苗
好懂黨務存也好
好懂AI也好
你看連這個東西都要知道
所有的這個
因為我是航運王啊你知道嗎
我是777出趙子龍
航運股你們想
來
這航運股
只有人都知道9月8月的時候是萬計
是
8月底
絕對通常都有出貨潮
要穿過運過他送到美國去
你說到美國去你不是
你美國去萬聖節
萬聖節11月
因為你在美國都會出
萬聖節10月底
10月底
10月底啊
沒錯啊
他不多的
10月底我送床
有時候送床
要連一兩個月
還落到二行
所以我八月就要送
所以9月底萬計就不見了
因為我順便
我萬聖節就要送
我一年算成季節
萬聖節
所以10月底
我也是10月初
10月底
對
好
你看
信號你去美國讀個書
10月底你八月就要裝戶
兩個月
所以你10月
萬聖節一送
還有聖誕節
是不是
對 還有感恩節
對不對
是不是感恩節什麼時候
感恩節是11月
11月嘛 什麼第幾個星期五是不是換季的
還是那是感恩節的那個消磋換季
不是
萬聖節 感恩節 聖誕節
10月11月12月
它會一起鋪貨
是
所以8月就會怎麼樣
就會運送的高潮
你們不要想歪了
我是說送貨的高潮
好運股會拉起來
所以你看到
陽明站拉百分之二
資本車
然後呢
長龍也這樣啦
我講陽明長龍汪海不是在你去買啊
而是告訴你景氣的衰退
通常不會9月以後啊
因為怎麼樣都會好啊
因為怎麼樣都會購物啊
萬聖節景氣不好你更會送禮物啦
多少會送禮物啦
那能不能
我是要強調我跟妳講的
現在買很safe啦
現在買很安全懂不懂
你看還運股就知道
送資料到萬聖節
港恩節
然後聖誕節
這是不是民主局的好聽嗎
這是什麼親民姐妹 親民主事情
我們台灣開玩笑
來這三個節
所以你八月就要送的運送
你買車子就知道了
有時候送過來運送要搬
兩個月三個月都要
有時候走海路的話
走會貴的話
一個月兩個月很正常
所以現在就要開始送貨
還要送貨到以後還要包貨
還要專載 還要到三櫃 到上價 上那個貨品櫃
都要時間的
所以下半年通常經濟 經濟 怎麼樣都不會太差
這是會讀 讀書的人不會跟你講這些
會做股票的人一定知道 沒有人
尤其沒有人會在12月做空 好不好 OK嗎
基本上沒有人會在12月做空 好不好
大家不要想不開 OK嗎
越到年底 越容易做多 越該做多
所以從航運股告訴你 今年
至少大家也準備了怎麼樣
聖大明節的景氣 萬聖節的景氣
所以在這邊 貨櫃有人說是先行指標
在那邊景氣到年底一樣
就再來一次 不會太差
你要看貨櫃股什麼時候還展生的
如果9月底 9月30號 9月25號
差不多了啦
9月底以後 運價還能上去
不是看股價 運價還能上去
那可能展真的 那就萬一整年
可是基本上不會上去的 好不好
OK嗎
所以這波大波 大戶五才會拉那麼
從貨櫃的走勢 告訴你
年底更應該做多
因為忘記又來了 忘記又來了
真的不知道
來來
來 看一下
我們來看一下大家有沒有什麼問題呢
環球金很好啊 拜拜環球金太多賞入了
環球金賞入不多 環球金有時候就看我的節目
其中學警怎麼樣 做等揮打法會下禮拜四嘛對不對
12月美國人業讓價錢只在做空 只會放空 腦袋放空
但股票不會做空 因為到最後會口袋空空
知道,OK嗎?
買美債安心,沒有,現在美債不要
美債只有一個人悲傷的世界,OK嗎?
台股量縮會下跌
量縮應該這樣講,量縮沒辦法撐住大盤
沒有讓大盤突破四萬八
量縮,我跟你講,量縮就像這種
你們的交過比說,哇,股市也是一樣
我們看一下
利安說三角收斂我們舉個慘龍意義好不好
三角收斂到極致有沒有看到
有沒有 這三角收斂到極致就會噴出去
就是利安說到極致的時候就像三角收斂到極致
要不要噴出去要不要往下這樣有沒有到
OK嗎 都不好意思用了
所以利安說只是告訴你
要決勝負 神奇寶貝
我們在決勝負的時候 大家留言說整個寶貝了
別別別別別
可是你們看到大家很現實 最近股票沒上來
大家就比較少稱我寶貝了
好像是
你們都很現實 都是復興漢
你們讀復興中學的嗎
還是捷運復興戰
中校復興戰
都是渣男
開玩笑的 都渣男
他說的不錯 我說的
沒有 我說的
沒有 女生說比較沒問題 男生說不行
好不好 來來 者者跑步 決勝負 來來
貨櫃為什麼長
來來 則技術分析簡單2要5800人
謝謝大家 來 中美金怎麼辦
我們先講好啊 中美金怎麼辦
我們先講新產籌碼好了
好不好 有好多人用中美金跟環球金
我們先講中美金 環球金 再講國際好了
來喔 這個我覺得國貸直率
每台直率還是可以下滑一點點
沒有那麼慘
來
莊美金換球金 現場莊美金好了
最近有新聞
做APF強料 莊美金贏轉單對不對
這是利多對不對
是
給我開高走低
怎麼會這樣
現在股市就大戶玩股票就是
我倆沒有明天
我們沒有明天
你錄完就走了
就走了
買完就走了啦
這個很扯
那這個什麼新聞我們看一下
來來
等一下
我們來看一下這個新聞來
ABI那個AIG影片的帶動槽有沒有看到
這個什麼AIG影片不是需求爆發嗎
ABI載板需求機增
2023年就機增了
那是ABU展一整 剛開始長
我印象很深刻
那時候我ABU載板賺翻了
然後我在去年 前年的時候
前年底去年的時候買
買ABU載板 買星星
100多元抵押7、80元 被人家罵的
好像混蛋一樣 現在都賺1000多元
那些罵我的 被那些其他分析師總有的
怎麼辦
最大問題是那些分析師
不要再每天扯一頁的話
會攻擊分析師的分析師
大部分是業績差
業績好 然後時間攻擊人家
我一定會講的錯吧
沒錯
沒有那種什麼你機效很好 業績很差
沒有這回事的
機效真的很好 續續不完的
對不對
沒錯
那個接口鱗區都會把你介紹了
就是業績不好
好不好
就是這樣子
所以不要去看那種會攻擊分析師的分析師
記得這樣
好啦 那扯遠了
那是ABU的載板 真的我從七八十塊
一路展到現在一千多塊
我好像三四百塊就走了
噗噗噗
沒關係
沒有關係啊
我真的喜歡買 就留一點給人家賺
我之前就留一點給人家賺
好啦 胃知數啦
聽起來好像是那種
那什麼胃圈的那什麼
素什麼 素精素什麼
胃精啦
胃精啦 對 胃精 聽起來像胃精
胃精不錯不錯
你休息的今天不錯 今天結構不錯
衛金啊 像衛金
你看衛金他說我選擇進出貨策略
我要優先滿足日系
台灣產商接貨公減三成產的
我沒有巧負攔為無米之吹
七六四三天大約百分之九十
精華科技
少數具備自主研發
你通過多數AI科物驗證明出貨
引轉單效率加速不取
這聽起來應該大力多
中美金本就控股集團
他旗下什麼環球金啊
十股也不傻
就能開高走低
這新聞如果是對的話
其實中美金今天大力多
至少有題材
要不要給你漲
對EPS影響不多
可是這有題材就會漲
莫名其妙
就是說
說
你挨握台股就說沒辦法
好不好
可是你看看我節目越嗨
說我們還是這麼多人去看我們的節目
為什麼
因為我們是有兼具娛樂性 搞笑性 跟專業性
專業最重要 起碼專業排第一
這個是真的利多啦 那利多
這本已經拉一起來拉個環球晶片
這環球晶片沒有 什麼位置
因為我跟你們講一件事
通通打第二支角
我們看一下 聯合同國劇都打第二支角
拚了 我跟你講 命一條 拚了
國劇真的有點太扯了 好不好
會不會破底
國際有的看起來我不知道會不會破底
破底機率很低
就算會破底也是假破底怎麼樣
到時候針穿頭會變掉
你知道嗎
是
就是真的破了也沒關係
就病因了
因為怎麼樣都比1200人來得好
好不好
破底以後說明那些1200人就會怎麼樣
大逃殺
全部砍掉砍掉
我這邊的人我砍掉我砍掉砍掉
就會拉起來
那為什麼
懂
現在要洗清福爾
來來 你看我今天做很多資料
越寒情我這個人就是很變態
越無聊的時候
我就會我反很多梗
含情越崩潰的時候反更越多信心
真的你多看
今天是不是很認真做資料來看一下
國劇我跟你講一下來
要求我這些人
國劇有沒有到
國劇股東的人數有沒有到
從多少
這國劇喔
從3幾從3幾萬有沒有到
5月22號20幾萬有沒有到
到現在變50幾萬對
太多人有了啦
以前一對沒聽過國句是不是
要聽過國句、樂句什麼都聽過
可能樂句國句你沒看幾個
可是股票國句你有聽過
大家都聽過
大家聽過
大家不會知道你樂句是什麼都不知道
算了 當然沒說過
戲劇的劇 再怎麼講
不要再扯了
國句 每個人都聽過了
是不是 從20幾萬到50幾萬
看一下 太扯了 我用簡單的來給你講
這個做這個圖我沒有意義
我今天跟威漢講不能做這張圖
要做這種圖就OK 看到 看到
本來22萬在這邊 有看到
5加629有沒有看到
威漢就做不多 恭喜大家考上分析師
明年這時候他應該就當分析師了
祝福他 所以你看我們訓練團隊
其實我們研究團隊都是分析師、台大、政大
都是這樣子的
好不好?快計師的都是這樣子的
都是非常非常厲害的
不然我們怎麼選出股票來?
選出那種標的標股
好不好?來
那你會選擇的最近股票不標
他說最近啊各位
不然就不是天天過年啊
你真的每次那麼厲害
我整個一買馬上展平反
還是你要等著下次
我再掏一億的時候
這跟我買 要等一年啊 你要等嗎
來
2020年5月22號有沒有看到股東22萬了 有沒有看到
有 股價629元有沒有看到
這邊一拉 從22萬變成35萬有沒有看到
20萬變30萬就很多人恐怖
那個要給我股價 這邊股價有
這邊從620元到850有沒有看到
股東增加10萬 很扯13萬
然後咧
然後再從怎麼樣
再從855元噴到
股東怎麼樣 增加到39萬噴到
有
最快的是這邊有沒有
600到800元噴到
這邊股東的數字增加很多
所以我們可以重新說
我也不認真了 難怪這一波跌到670幾元開始殺下來
因為最多就這一塊嘛 從622到855元
有沒有 增加13萬人有沒有 是
是不是 那這一波不是談到670幾元嗎
是不是 就殺下來
因為這波 因為這波
因為增加600多到800是增加人數最多
13萬人
很多人 我解套了 我趕快走了
差不多我套牢了 她小陪了我走了
好 到這邊1220元這附近的時候
39萬人還好 可你看
殺到 39萬人 你看到
再殺下去的時候
這一波殺下去
股東人數從39萬變50萬
又增加
聽懂嗎? 懂
現在唯一的好處是怎麼樣
人總算減少3000人
0.3萬人
很恐怖的是我們在給你總結
你看我們做的圖很漂亮
大概啦
700元以上我要跟著
有700元上可能就有點壓力了
快700元
有沒有到
接近700元以上
是不是
是
股東人數從22萬22.5萬
到多少
大概差不多到54萬
成不成
好誇張喔
32萬的服裝籌碼這邊通通被套了
難怪講國劇那麼多
多32萬人
兄弟們起來
我身本很低,不用怕,拉回來買
他們受不了,所以洗清服務要一段時間
Mato,Mashi,第二個還有什麼原因?
來,萬事具備指千頭風,他現在萬事都不具備
你要等誰?春田製作所,請你要怎麼樣?
春田製作所,這相關的全部要納入考量
來 看一下
淡一淡
怎麼沒有春田製作
春田製作
陳哲要求很嚴厲 現在我就會念一下威漢
不過沒差 但事先要念他 等他當分析的時候
我就決口不提他 我是這種人
因為沒什麼好提的 就是我會祝福他
也不算就是 沒什麼好提示說
我不要讓大家覺得單分醫師就支持他
我不會讓大家覺得說
哇 他還是菜鳥 你知道嗎
把他講成像菜鳥 我不喜歡
但是因為他現在還沒有
雖然考上分機師 但是還沒有正式的就是
就是開始遭受會員
因為他要訓練一陣子 我們莫站
我們莫單分醫師這樣子
有些人是單分醫師
也會投過單分醫師的
看你帥 你去單分醫師了 OK嗎
我們沒有 我們是一定要經過訓練的
燒折兩年
我一看來這邊已經快一年的時間了
來
春天製作所來看一下
比他頭光模仿也沒有用
因為我親自教的這個模仿
是
對
春天製作所你看為什麼我練武衣漢
你看一下 做分析師
你看門道 你不要看我們模分析師的特別講
我可以說
我可以說 做治安圖對不對
是不是
治安圖對不對
不夠明顯 因為字很小
我只要做清楚一點
結果要給我做清楚以後
怎麼樣 我回去念他
你知道我回去念他嗎
奇怪 你看出來什麼ABC波嗎
看了出來股價從高沙下來嗎
所以我一看做這張圖很不行
所以你們看喔 同樣是分析師
同樣在做圖就差很多了
要解這個 你不覺得這樣解釋
這一張走勢圖
比較像國劇的走勢圖嗎
真的耶
你看我一看做這一張圖
就完全不像國劇的走勢圖
我想多要多 浪費我全部時間
大家一萬多人聽怎麼當分析師
所以你不要看我是很變態
我是非常管教 非常演的
你看 這樣是怎麼看得出來 跟過去有像
他也不動腦輪怎麼辦
是不是 自然看起來跟過去有像嘛 對不對
你看一下就知道 是不是
所以陳鐵之路跟過去有像
阿哲哲有點像 歪軸再拉長一點就可以了
好不好 歪軸就是把它拉長一點
比例把它拉長一點 是不是又有點像
沒錯吧 拉長一點
三十月像 四十月像國際對不對
所以春田製作所 圖很重要
春田製作所 股價看起來要打第二支角
我恐怖喔 你不要怕
就是我回答我的重點
我就直覺告訴你了 我今天要告訴你了
我說沒有人在下半年 尤其十二月做空
股價通常是九月之前
那你說有些是沒辦法如果你來個地震
來個打戰那個我們沒辦法預測
對
可是股災通常經濟的股災
經濟的股災通常9月之前就結束了
為什麼?
因為9月以後我要鋪貨
我只要一片石頭在前面
一片石頭漂亮
你懂不懂?
我要投資
懂不懂?
OK嗎?傳統萬計
這個給你補充一下
航運股的走勢看起來真的要鋪貨了
是不是?
是
一片石頭漂亮是不是?
這邊拉股你就做多你怕什麼
你會怎麼買一些電子產品嗎?
變動員間有那麼差嗎?
本業有成吧?是不是?
是
我看到重點,你要疊到400元
你要記得一件,你們兄弟,
康當一下好不好?
他也才兩、三百元這樣漲而已
你要疊到300元
人家是這邊而已,你就知道疊破頭
人疊多少啊?
冷靜啊,現在充滿亂
我跟你講一件事
我看最好0098,通通賣觀光
我還包著他賣官房,我是認真的
他賣官房上去1200,你不會覺得我是最厲害的
雖然我不需要跟他比,他是主動式ETF
我不好意思,我就是霸氣
我告訴你,非東一間看好,但是由此一說
基底還是很強
基底本益比那麼低,非東元件
他獲利還沒那麼高,本益比很高,沒EDP
誰叫你要比基底,我不需要比基底
我只要國際800元以上 要求不多啦
有機會籌碼亂 加上國外的被動元件
股價也下去 也打第二隻腳
就這兩個原因 沒用什麼原因好不好
怎麼樣 我最喜歡一部電影
《爛子彈飛一回》 OK嗎
講這東西不講政治 你也挺常聽小看對不對
我有聽過 你有聽過 這部電影很好看
還不錯 跟對岸 跟什麼我喜歡
我什麼都看 我什麼歷史故作看
爛子彈飛 這是扯遠的
這不是重點 爛子彈飛毀啊 各位
OK嗎?
籌碼亂那麼多人是不是?
是不是 OK嗎?
怎麼看台積電拉尾盤?
股市拉起來
好不好?
國際買到510 620沒賣掉
來 台慶科就跌回原點
那基本面差不多
霸氣則保
謝謝你 仔仔寶貝 是不是
黃耀金習舞很久了 好不好
昨天給我家貓看 他說他興奮到哈棄
哈棄 哈棄是 哈棄是開心嗎
應該是呼嚕呼嚕才是開心嗎
哈棄好像貓咪 哈棄是
你不是養貓嗎
哈棄是有點兇的意思
對啊 你到底會養貓啊
怎麼會這樣
是啊 你看一下
川普爸爸昨天給我家貓看著摺
他興奮到哈氣
一看就知道你慘了
你根本就虐待貓
你根本不懂貓的開心
你看我還懂 我都有設略
好開心 呼嚕
他又呼嚕
呼嚕
是不是 哈氣是他不高興 不耐煩
你這個叫明包暗扁我
昨天給我家貓看著摺
他興奮到哈氣
你再表達不耐煩 好不好
不過貓的確是這樣子
你不能給他太大聲音
刺激他
對 貓的感覺
他有時候會刺激他你知道嗎
是
有些貓你看有些人比如說有些貓
哇 那個會抓主人
都是你們自己發出尖銳的聲音你知道嗎
你突然發尖銳的聲音
他對聲音很敏感
其實貓會攻擊人家
或者洗澡的時候會攻擊人家
最重要是什麼呢
他是受到刺激
他其實他膽子很小
很膽子很小
你越刺激他就會反擊
是這樣子的
重點是這樣
天涯的投資長真的什麼都知道
我什麼都懂
其實我很怕貓
因為我鼻子不好
我會過敏
那也會過敏
對啊 可是你什麼都知道
你看 都了解是不是
是 什麼知道
因為你養貓是不是
有
是不是 你們要了解貓就知道了
講話不要那麼大聲好不好
來 成員的
請問 男生你們男生
記得一件事
如果要怎麼樣
要追女生就知道
多了解貓 你知道嗎
還有共通話題
我真的只能 因為這原因
直播破六千人的還好啦
這是實際上全能 謝謝大家
經濟怎麼看 經濟觀看人數不少
攔下列車來接人喔
來來
邏輯最強的帥者請問緊述
剛才不是說ABU的載板
ABU的缺料怎麼好
缺料怎麼好
所以這貼臉貼 缺料不好啦
OK嗎
ABU的載板缺料不好 是不是
他是搶中
他是把中國的ABU的載板不理他啦
你懂我意思嗎
剛才那個未知數
外資買了280.3億,所以還不錯耶
算強的耶,因為轉成美國股市
我記得沒錯,斬跌貨件不是嗎
是不是
沒有理由
我說這個怪怪的
廢半跟納稅
其實我覺得這個很特別
感覺外資買盤回來了
是不是 像台幣多少 31.8% 前面只要32.3% 三十年也死
你看單分一直要懂很多數字
怪怪的 因為基本上這個納斯拉克的點那麼兇
廢半閃那麼少 基本上今天不會是買鈔
所以今天外資可能開始 可能用一個部分是因為
他覺得美在不值錢 我講美在是垃圾也可以上新聞
再講一次 美在就是垃圾 我就買最多垃圾的男人
不會我愛你們 好不好 記得一件事
1.71美債就是我買了,買了又放著,等賺2000幫他再走
誰叫我這個莫言
倒窮廢半,廢半跟納斯拉克
所以今天外資買超兩倍多也很特別,很少會這樣子買
記著這樣子
中美金投信來乾建倉,我覺得是跌假的
我看一下中美金
其實以前中美金蠻喜歡那樣子
我的股票
你知道星星那時候七十幾塊的時候根本沒人理我
我看很遠的啦
七十幾元我真的覺得接下來會缺貨
真的耶 你們會看耶
欸
對喔 你看喔
欸 你滿厲害的喔
我們看到中美金玩到 之前278元玩到
一堆買七千多張玩到
真的 那時候累積量玩到
多少
二 我們看一下
按到 馬上按一下給大家聽
你看到278元的門道
然後買個1萬多的賺不到
那時候成交累積量27萬的門道
看不到沒關係 我跟你講
好 有三下去 因為量而減少
是外資減 投信其實應該
投信有些人賣掉了 好不好
買11000站這邊陸續賣掉
你講的沒錯 這不錯 這連三日買
這應該有主動型一貼服 好不好
你們查一下 我到時候我也查一下
這應該有主動型一貼服的認養他 可以放大嗎
對 它剛太小
之前沒有放大 對
投信對不對 對
最近買的 應該要一兩檔主動型一貼服的認養
這蠻特別的 好不好
那從本金上去 換金金不會上去
我跟你講 你剛換金金投信你在買
我居然在認養 怪怪的
我的節目你覺得沒有人會看
很多經紀人是我信徒
只是他們不會承認
好不好
沒有關係 我都祝福你們好不好
只是講話有時候很討厭
節目效果你們不要緊張
姚思清母也是一樣
你要不要買 你要不要賣
各做各的沒有關係
我都愛你們
來啦
一氣功 我的股票也沒關係
有在買喔
有在買喔 你們認真喔 是不是
其實現在投信的規模有變小
你都什麼 規模變大兩種
一種是我錢投進去
一種是我的錢變大
比如說我股票從1000塊漲到2000塊
我規模是應該變一倍
如果股票都變一倍的話
像規模說縮減
因為股票就沒漲
自己那些沒漲
定存定額有進去也不會那麼快
所以他們現在還有錢
買環球金都已經要注意一下
你看我們這家Sense是很多
你看我已經看很多東西了
可是他玩友這個方面怎麼看
我們變成聯好的互動了,有沒有看到
哲哲寶貝救救性餐店
星期五直播人數會打折
有人請假出去玩,最近蠻多的
來來
7000多人,今天7000個禮拜我算多了
按這個帳好不好
按一次帳就好,按兩次帳會減少好不好
哲哲寶貝自圓來跟大家講
走吧 來來
外資最垃圾
信餐店
美來
來來
我服了 來來 我們跟大家講
華興跟國具一樣
華興科我想買了
華興科哪一天我買了 你不要覺得奇怪
被動元件 我跟你講 不能那麼差的
都未缺 AI都未缺 邊緣運算未缺
我從頭到尾 國具一千五
不理他 可是我國劇100個500元
有沒有機會到800到1000
也有機會860%、1600%、成本不同決定的高度
成本不同決定的高度 OK嗎
知道
這跟大家講 大家有沒有問題
來 管達前面買金還有錢嗎
管達這種苦就沒什麼 不要想太多
剛剛講到匯率的影響 匯率在升值
那為什麼你這樣知道
你美債不值錢 有些人就不會買美債
甚至把美約
所以不買美債
你懂不懂
不買美債的人要怎麼辦
有些是國外資金
美債沒有意義
我就把美債賣掉 會為台幣
會為台灣
會台灣幹嘛 就買股票
你懂不懂
所以美債不值錢 很多人會玩美國是為了買美債
我美債我不想買
我現在是因為你們關係
你叫我現在認賠1000萬我也沒差
因為我快台灣50賺回來
我是認真的
你們百分之百說沒問題
不要再百分之百 百分之九十五都沒問題
我一定馬上賣
你賣 我很開心
我不許我賠錢 哇 我覺得我少賺一億
是真的 如果我能換成台灣五十
所以很多人把美債
現在美債是不是 我跟你講 你看 我的東西都一套的
直率很高
為什麼直率很高 因為很少人買美債
因為美債本來以前不知道餐飲照變四十照
東西越來越不值錢
是 高級越來越多 就東西不值錢
就台灣醫生
如果我們台灣醫生像菲律賓醫生一樣
哇 我不設限啦 是不是 中國不設限
那台灣醫生薪水就會降低了
但台灣醫生很優秀 還有因為他們等等特殊很聰明
可是如果人數變多 一樣薪水會打折
所以攻擊跟需求才是決定這個價格
美債攻擊那麼多 美債數量那麼多 價格下滑
價格下滑 美債職位善生 真的嗎
好 我剛講美債職位是不是善生了
價格下滑你就會賣掉美債了
賣掉美債 我乾脆我連美元都不要
我就換回台幣了 好不好
所以對股市還是有點止沉
OK嗎?
OK
這跟大家講
有人洗一把
這一週取幾隻健身房
大概一週
因為我不是臭屁
人家就我看很賺對不對
你們不要羨慕
因為最近比較累
因為年紀大了
不是講年紀大
工作太忙了
我比較喜歡輕運動
跑步
有養比較重要
重訓你們看到很多人肌肉量到老的時候
肌肉量太大 那是負荷
那令到很像壯的像星星反而都找死你知道嗎
真的喔
真的喔 因為你對你清淡這種負荷
你看很多你看管子能知道
你看他有以前壯嗎 沒有
到最後都是這樣子
他什麼魯尼還羅尼
就是有一個幾屆的健身冠軍
到最後都不良於行
所以剛好就好了
剛好就好了 所以我一個禮拜
但一個禮拜大概健身一次
有時候兩週一次我還是可以維持肌肉量
全部不一定羨慕我
肌肉長得很快
天生肌肉長得很快
可是這沒什麼需要的啦
你難道是因為看我肉體還喜歡我嗎
不會吧
可能有喔
你這樣子我很尷尬
你在喵哪裡
不跟你開玩笑了啦
聽完笑
老人要重訓對
老人一定要重訓 因為很多人就是一疊一疊的就拜拜
老人家這連鎖反應很重要
問題是我還沒老啊 各位
我的70歲 我有重訓值比較少 好不好
來來 練出來一點 是是是
還沒對你說是為了身材者跟我在一起
你們怎樣 你們怎樣 還是
不需要試好不好
練重點 練小小的
你連重電大大折可不可以
大大折還四四四
你們真的是為我肉體來的
你們不是為我腦袋
好啦就跟大家講
我看不到300的紅海
我買三隻沒有三隻
你說你買三隻紅海你被套牢
你剛好而已
三張還是三股啊我都不知道
數量要對 單位要對
還四 要深蹲 喔我有深蹲
開玩笑生對很重要 你知道嗎
男人就是要生對
好不好
不多說自己去做
剛剛竟然有持窮的時候
我不是持窮 我是被你們意淫
不好意思
今天外帶你一頂頭髮
什麼我頭髮是真的 你別擺頭
肉體是配型
好啦 不用拿地賽
來 我們看一下
腰力
我蝙蝠腳幹了 找個是什麼東西 我不知道這梗
你們今天好嗨 我頭好暈
來 剛才講什麼東西
剛才講什麼 你們應該不是在洗板了 你們
大家心情我很開心 你們在洗板你知道嗎
木村都在那裡 做尾川怎麼辦
臉紅的深蹲舊傳說 深蹲舊地球
深蹲一下好不好 深蹲你自己開心一點
今天我深蹲可以解開扣子 我解一個好不好
不要鬧了啦
Rawens不要鬧了好不好
來 華班店跟尾川是不是垃圾骨
常常開盤開高走地
我有點想買華班店
我不是說華班店
就機起來講有點高
沒有啊 我有看你要噴出去啦
哪有啊 華班店很強好不好
我滿看我華班店的
其實我是真的
這一天是有點想買
我頭暈啦 哎呀
我還在想啦 好不好
機體還是會拉起來的啦
我跟你講 還是會缺的啦
我講機體跟TVU今天不一樣
我們這就缺很久啦
好不好
這我講的 缺就是會缺 好不好
然後我們就要什麼股票還沒講
098A 都不管它了 好不好
你們要賣就賣 反正我看遠
我們還是要回到重點 我最後再講一件事
來 Modena的疫苗 講一次 Modena的疫苗怎麼樣
Fast6AI Modena的疫苗
選出從AI遠算法裡面選出什麼
34個關鍵的圖片圓
可以編碼RNA 製造疫苗
個人化疫苗
你知道那黑身素流
你去問醫界的人
醫生留言好不好
你們不要因為參加者則
當者則粉絲是粉絲榮幸好不好
你們自己說醫界就知道
這個很難
拜託個人化疫苗
社務陷害10個
我真的看了研究
超過30%還是50%到70%到80%的時候
都有社務陷害
其實社務陷害是比較
大部分是比較溫和的
比較輕微
就你到老到死 他都伴隨著你 有些愛就是這樣子
你知道嗎? 私惡物現矮也可以救活
哇塞 黑色素流也可以 肺癌也是可以
哇 台灣肺癌的人數很多 你知道嗎?
來 哲之前你切了些諧解
所以這都OK 你知道嗎?
OK是什麼意思?
AI真的改變人生了 你們不要開玩笑
你知道嗎?
我昨天跟一群歷史吃飯 我還說
他們認同 我有個律師
因為拖那些分析師的事情
通常這些分析師我提到的事情
搞到現在 像幾分啊
搞到現在 則則非常了解 法院訴訟的事情
我說你們這樣不需要法助了
要不要律師問法助 以前是個法律 為什麼
改條文會東露西露
那個就像下象棋一樣 下象棋除非你是棋丸等級
不然一定有疏露的時候 連棋丸都下象棋都疏人家
像不是 你那個合約第一條跟第五條 如果有一點護士
違背 後面哪一天少寫的 你知道嗎 你問他
現在不是有什麼陳迅雲 不是嗎
哇 陳迅雲最近八卦 這個也可以問他
所以那個時候就是趙建民就是可惜 沒有人捐回來
這個又上新聞了 我跟你講
問什麼 趙建民把那個什麼保密條款
離婚的保密條款拿去小感機場發 你知道嗎
本身這個就是怎麼樣
本身這個 然後說你陳迅雲你要賠儀
暗示他 陳迅雲說我問我的律師
你連條款本身都不能講了
你講的以後就是
保密條款就連保密都不能講了
你知道嗎
連保密那種法醫都不能講了
你講的你也要賠醫
互相指責對方要賠醫
趙建民本來可以告他醫醫你知道嗎
那這個就好玩了
這個就要建法律
因為說好說好 陳信勻是真的爆料了
他可能是要輸這醫
你知道嗎
趙建民如果用Gimbal來用AI的話
怎麼樣
他可能就不會去發這個東西
他說只能說我們要保密條款
我準備提告 戰將就好了
你懂我意思嗎
這樣他就勝算機率很高
他本來就有機會贏了
可是到時候可能要
也要 我培議 你也要培議
那就沒意思了
只要用AI 少了法律助理
那個趙建民多優秀
台大一科的多優秀
是不是 兩多優秀
少用AI 你懂不懂
我想是真的
會用AI的人會贏很多人你知道嗎
可是其實我們那天還在討論
連綠絲的討論
以後能怎麼辦
很多人會被淘汰
因為一個人像我現在做事情
很多事情我都不找合約,我自己做比較快
因為我直接問AI,架構寫合約公司
每天要寫很多合約,每天要寫一些合約內容
那其實找律師還不一定寫得好
因為他會漏,你知道嗎?
OK嗎?來,保密就不能說,來
每一股夜盤想要長怎麼看?來
紅矮說看不到300真的看不到
你們要諷刺,我說再也看不到300
我那時候說看不到300,我完全沒增加
那時候台積電我就看不到600,還不是被他笑一陣子
現在誰叫誰
前陣子2,500
是不是 OK嗎
來來 美在時率居高不下
好啦 就這樣子 最後幾分了
我只要結束了 今天有沒有害
我不要講了
管達外毀算等有量在縮
這個全足股美量能怎麼辦
是不是
那個花新科我覺得可以買
我覺得那個誰
這都是交加集團的
華班店我覺得也不錯啦
我剛好中美金跟環球金投資在投買了
而且感覺是在養他 感覺在認養的
他們應該跟我一樣
已經預期到明年會大缺貨 明年缺貨金很高
我不敢說百分之百 我們是合格分醫師
我是合格分醫師 股資有賺有賠
可是如果你就是覺得
整個是你認識最認真最優秀的最幽默
或是你為了肉體 竟然不要為了肉體
好 你覺得可以把你賺錢的本金吃
歡迎來這期下旬 080 06 8080 或者叫我賴思虛
不論對我做者者一切一切 預告前面
量輸了 急滯之後就有一個方向
台舊補台股下半年萬計要開始
趕快來一起來跟我賺大錢
我一起我努力 盡我一切努力
來幫你大家賺大錢 謝謝各位 拜拜
緊繃參考 投資人應獨立判斷 指示評估並自負投資風險